that was wrong
[Music]
okay we're back um
i guess random mode was was a mixed
success so now we try hard modes
and um i actually haven't tried hard
mode before
only only random i've been i've been
doing so
first first uh first exercise wasn't
that difficult
next one i think we just gotta protect
against mate
protect the bishop knight before
bish b3 and the fork
oh this one that's a nice theme
queen of six and wherever wherever you
block there's always a perpetual
nice like that one
is there's something special here i
think just queen d3 right
change the queens
that is tough
let's just take the knight the knight of
fate
i don't see anything wrong with it turns
out
it was correct nice
so how do we protect against the mates
looks pretty tough
rookie 4 and then run
i don't love it but i don't see anything
else
seems like the only chance now
okay still didn't look very promising
though
okay i think we gotta go for a little
drawing combination here
um
knight f4 could work bishop d2
takes c8 king a7 as not to allow the
fork on c5
then we take an h8
it doesn't look oh maybe bishop d1 of
course yeah that's it
it's much easier than that queen a3
trapping the knights
[Music]
okay we're run only chance
what a tricky move
actually queen f6 is not unfeasible
bishop g5
fg
i feel like that's not the solution
though
what to do i'm gonna go for it
it was correct wow
that was amazing that needed i should
have had to show more
i think
96 looks good forcing the queen away
so we just grabbed the rook and we're
off material okay
knight g6 very
nice oh my game against duda
like not the greatest memories
yeah i did play differently on the game
and it was drawn so it was not obvious
that white was winning that
just f y i
oh this is nice i think e4 d e queen h4
king f5 queen of four king e6 queen c4
and win the queen
okay just take g4
how about we suck the queen
nah i think bishop just just bishop d6
winning the piece that's better
rook d1 what a tricky move
and i would say fairly uncalled for just
one is a simple win here
okay we go back um yeah
don't overthink dude
roxy one nice
theme
okay queen f6 i guess it's more accurate
because you covered d4
then you just win
okay so you're playing black and you go
queen d4 and then this is queen the pawn
queen b5 i think take c7
take g7 take green piece up
windy four
it's got to be rook g8
can we give a check no
oh 25 first maybe
well first mistake
of the day okay check check we take then
queen edge one
nice take the rook
what else we push the pawn
make the and we'll push it again
okay move the rook attack the bishop
what's not to like
94 was was better
okay that was a bit lazy
but h3 saves tonight
i really want to go queen d4 here
that was wrong ugh
gotta speed up
out of sex trapping the queen
what
seven always some track
we have three and then take it
okay win the rook
tricky don't have time for this
three
doesn't seem to lead to much
i don't know i don't think that was too
too too great
but that's the way it is some of those
were pretty difficult i just wanna i
just wanna see what mistakes i made
yeah it was queen e5 immediately
yeah i thought so too
my idea was to go knight e3 and then
king e2 and then queen e5
but i didn't really see what to do after
queen c3
i mean i black is certainly a lot better
but maybe it's uh it's a bit rush
but yeah taking immediately was
was clearly better and yeah as i said 94
just one that was a bit lazy
oh i thought about queen d4 queen d4
bish b6 but i didn't really see what to
do against queen d7
maybe just then knight b5 as well
i guess that does the trick
oh it says king v8 but now now knight b5
is quite trivial
queen moose i don't think you can even
go rook c7
but yeah rook c7 queen e6
take yeah nice
you win at the very least a few points
and here
king b8
oh oh the king is six
okay nice king e6 distance opposition
right
so king b7 king d7 king b8 king the
eighth
king a8 king e8
and you have to go king e8 because if
king c8 king a7
king c7 king a6 you're out flanked
and uh the king eventually will enter
and gobble up all the pawns
but if you keep the distance opposition
instead you cannot be outflanked
so that's pretty instructive
okay
okay so we give a check and then root b3
okay it wasn't wasn't harder than that
i like a4 allowing mates on two two
squares obviously white has to try
rookie seven here okay rook
rook b3 that was really nice
okay um a few
avoidable mistakes there but um
generally
um some nice puzzles
[Music]
you